so that would be remiss and not honoring
Terence Mckenna
who do many of you probably know who
died recently and Terence and I became
very good friends the last four or five
years of his life one of the reasons why
Terence and I became very good friends
he started making fun of himself you
know I enjoy that if you don't have a
sense of self humor or self-criticism
then I think that's that's a real
problem you have to be able to laugh at
yourself and and Terence has come up
with some really astonishing concepts
and ideas about the interstellar
transportation of germ plasm of fungi
throughout space well that was
absolutely scientific heresy 15 20 years
ago but most of you probably are well
aware that this theory is getting more
and more substantiating that into spores
of bacteria and fungi may well be able
to survive interstellar space travel and
perhaps this planet was seeded with Enda
spores of bacteria and fungi long ago
and was on the sense of knock you lated
and I suspect that the fungi are
throughout the cosmos wherever there is
water carbon hydrogen nitrogen you're
gonna end up with linear chains of
self-replicating self-replicating matter
running through mitosis you know it's
projects mice ileal networks and evolve
into fungi I think fungi or is if you
have matter you're gonna have fungi
you know that's my belief I think
Terence was really on the right track in
so many ways several books were being
produced if we have focus again that
were being produced at this time and
probably the one of the worst books was
this one and this one this book here
said that you could take meat all which
is a chemical agent used in photography
you could put it on the mushrooms they
turn blue then the mushrooms were active
absolutely not true a lot of
misinformation came out and then a
number of other books the kind of a
second generation of books came out that
were much much better this is Steven
Pollock's buck this is my first one
Jonathan Ott's first book Terence
Mckenna and Dennis McKenna wrote the
suicide magic mushroom Growers guide
which really started a revolution here
in the Bay Area I call it the Selassie
be cubensis scholarship fund you know
because many many people have come up to
me you know after I've said that about
the Selassie God commands a scholarship
on saying you know I was one of those
people you know who a little bit
cubensis in their closet you know they
never made it much money but they paid
tuition they paid their rent
they were law-abiding citizens otherwise
but this is Salafi cubensis this is
opposed to the most prominently
well-known psilocybin active mushroom in
the world this is the one that Terrence
and Denis went down to the Amazon
they ate these mushrooms they had these
visions of flying saucers coming from
outer space and this invisible war all
around them and they then pioneered
using a work from San Antonio which is a
mycologist scrolling button mushrooms
using a case grain technique of growing
this mushroom mycelium on on rye grain
and then and putting soil on top and
growing up very easy mushrooms to grow
very prevalent very common a
southeastern United States
it also circumnavigates the the
equatorial region of the planet so it's
in Thailand it's in Central America it's
in the Philippines you know it's in
India it's it's all over the world
[Music]